he's my example one don't worry I'm
gonna give you a nice big table with all
of that sort of looking results and
everything you need to have sort of
remember okay but my when I learned to
drive
we're gonna go port to drive start again
well my brother got taught to drive I
mean he was like turning up coming up to
a certain kind of turn it's like okay
there's a 90-degree turn you need to put
the hands here and turn your hands
exactly some number of degrees and then
you need to release this minion blow
along and if you come through if you're
turning right at like a roundabout your
turn lift this many degrees and you turn
this right this mean degrees you turn
left and so on right
and sorry oh good point now here's the
thing right it's not the same it's sort
of generally close but the point is that
when my brother would that way right
there's a danger to learning ah this is
exactly how it works each time and then
you just sort of formulaic ly apply it
mechanically without thinking so way I
learned was actually I didn't know
anything about you you turn them to this
March for you go this and then this and
then that Mike my instructor he just
kind of said okay here we go
there's no one here you can kill except
for possibly yourself in a marionette me
next to even I like my seat Heather in
airbags so yeah anyway he said look just
develop your sense of how it works right
and then we'll add in the the rules
later on okay so that's what I'm trying
to do here so I'm just freaking out
specific examples and we will get a big
table of memorize Abul results later I
want you to try and see how it works all
right coming back now we're down to root
3 is about 1.7 their mouths okay so I
think if you divide it by 2 that should
be like point eight five or something
like that
now the range of cosine is one so I'm
pretty close to the top so when I draw
in my line like so I think that's
roughly where it's going to be okay so
I'm calling out y equals root 3 on 2
okay now where is the first solution
going to be deteriorate
your first solution for this equation is
pile on six okay close upon six is root
three or two right
so that corresponds to here we just not
too bad it's a bit off because that's
been to me pine but you get the idea
okay now how do I go from that solution
to all the other ones okay well some of
them are more obvious than others for
instance we know that the period of
cosine just like the sign is two pi
right so if I go two pi radians from
here forward I'm gonna land on like the
solution right so turns out if you go to
2 pi forward you're gonna land on this
one
this solution over here okay so Pilon 6
plus 2 pi what's that going to be not 7
pi that's early one time 13 pi on 6 ok
now you can see our mister solution
we'll come back to it in a second
politics 13 politics I could go again do
the same trick I'll land over here and
I'll get to 25 pi on 6 and I can do it
again and so on
ok so there's some of my solutions I
take this upon 6 then I add 2 pi so pi +
6 + 2 5 point 6 + 4 pi I guess plan 6 vs
6 PI + 8 PI and so on but you can see
I've missed all these ones in between
right so how do I catch them well
instead of going forward 2 pi right look
at the symmetry here okay so you think
about this is 0 to 2 pi sets on one lot
the first time to get to this answer I
went forward policies to get the other
one because of this symmetry I have to
go backwards policies right so here I'm
2 pi is kind of like my axis of symmetry
I have forward politics to get 1 in its
up and I go backwards
other ones so this one's going to be a
lemon pie right and then again you can
see the same trick up here this is the
soup line that was my access before this
is for pot so to get one answer I went
forward five six and get the other one
I've got to go backwards right so I
guess that would be 23 ok so how can I
roll it all together well look at these
a look at these odd lots of pi 1 pi 3 PI
by PI not because really happening
around it is it ok everything's about
these even lots of pipes Europe 2 pi 4
PI that's where all the action is ok sir
how do i express all of the even lots of
pies and skip will be on ones well put
the end actually at the front because we
sort of read it as 0 PI to PI of core PI
of 6 PI right now after you get through
those even lots of PI of what did we say
we have to do you have to go forward
your little angle and you have to go
backwards so forward and backwards is
plus or minus right and then you take
this little related angle and that's
what you're going backwards or forwards
don't forget we introduced this n ok so
you've got to say what is it an integer